for 17 days after Jamal keshavjee
entered its consulate in Istanbul and
disappeared inside the Saudi government
insisted he'd left unharmed but Turkish
intelligence have recorded every step of
the journalist abduction torture and
murder inside the building and every
movement of the Saudi hit team
- from the country they had come and
left on Saudi government planes and were
identified as Saudi government agents
the Saudi story unraveled quickly
today's news is the country's latest
attempt out of several to explain what
happened blaming a number of unnamed
individuals who've now been sentenced to
death but the CIA has already concluded
that this man was almost certainly
ultimately responsible Saudi Crown
Prince and de facto ruler Mohammed bin
Salman UN Special Rapporteur on
extrajudicial killing Agnes Callum are
treated today the masterminds not only
walk free they've barely been touched by
the investigation and the trial that is
the antithesis of justice it is a
mockery one alleged mastermind is soured
al Kitani a close confident of Mohammed
bin Salman and believed by the US
government to have planned the killing
the Saudi court ruled there was no
evidence with which to try him for
casualties murder Amnesty International
says the process was a whitewash
observers say the Saudi government is
desperate to move on from the disastrous
murder everybody knows that this is just
the cover-up that they're trying to do
so the reason is being is that Mohammed
bin Salman knows that to this day that
he has been unable to convince people in
order to buy into his vision he's
worried that his position now is
starting to become increasingly
untenable this week before today's news
1 Saudi royal and veteran diplomat
admitted to me in London that the
keshavjee murder has done lasting damage
to his kingdom I personally worked with
Jim asaji when he was when I was
ambassador here he was my press
spokesman and when I was in Ambassador
in the US he was my press spokesman
there as well and his loss is a
devastating blow to all of us so it is
not an issue that we are going to forget
Saudis and
but I tell everybody that unfortunately
it's a stigma that we have to bear and
will continue to be sorry rabies young
Prince mayor hopes releasing the news on
a week from Western governments and many
observers are on holiday would draw a
line under this affair with a minimum of
scrutiny but the ghost of Jamal
khashoggi is likely to haunt the House
of Saud for a long time to come
Dominik Waghorn sky news